Hallo, schon jemand da?
Oh, wisst ihr was ich sehe? Twitch ist wieder der Meinung, ich habe keine Qualitätsoptionen heute und heute sind es 720p, 60 fps, ich habe das Gefühl Twitch hat da irgendwas geändert, weil ich hatte früher immer, immer Quality Optionen und in letzter Zeit immer nur Source oder Auto, ich weiß nicht was da los ist.
Ich hatte jetzt zwei Monate lang immer Quality Optionen, immer, aber jetzt nicht und ich weiß nicht warum ehrlich zu sein.
Ich meine, habe ich zu hohe Bitrate? Ich kann nicht, ich habe nichts geändert.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich habe zu hohe, ich kann nicht zu hohe Bitrate haben, ich habe nichts getan, hat sich, ne?
Ich gucke mir das jetzt gerade mal an, Video Statistik anzeigen, ja exakt, so mal kann das sein, dass man das nicht mal angezeigt kriegt.
Leute, kann, kriegt ihr noch, wenn ihr, wenn ihr euch die Video Statistik anzeigen lasst, ne, von meinem Video, kriegt ihr da noch angezeigt, wie viel Bitrate das ist, das steht bei mir jetzt gar nicht mehr drinnen.
Warum, wo ist das hin? Show Video Stats, ja das zeigt, das zeigt bei mir nichts mehr an.
Das zeigt, das zeigt bei mir, nein doch Playback Rate, Playback Rate, ah ja, ich musste mal richtig gucken, doch Playback Rate steht da, ich glaube Playback Rate ist, ist das?
Ach auf Deutsch heißt das Speicherauslastung, ok, weil dann haben sie das einfach nur falsch übersetzt, weil wenn ich mir das auf Englisch im Browser angucke heißt das Playback Rate 6000 Kilobits, also das passt, das habe ich auch genau eingestellt.
Das muss, oh ich muss mein Bot noch einstellen, mein Bot ist immer noch der Meinung, ich bin heute ziemlich im Arsch, das bin ich zwar auch, aber das, ach komm ich lasse den Text jetzt einfach drinnen stehen, scheiß drauf.
Ich würde dir gerne ein Google Drive Link für Gameplay zukommen lassen, aber halt nicht öffentlich, also per DN oder so ähnlich, du kannst mir das per YouTube PM schicken oder per Business E-Mail oder per Twitch PM, keine Ahnung, am liebsten eigentlich per YouTube PM.
So, dann würde ich mal sagen, nochmal den Text weg.
Hallo Romanjo, wir spielen heute mal ein Puzzle Game, was ich schon immer mal spielen wollte, was ich seit 2000, ach ich weiß es nicht, 2000, Moment, man kann das doch in Steam nachgucken, seit wann ich das in der Bibliothek habe oder runtergeladen, ne sieht man nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung, gefühlt seit 8 Jahren oder so auf Steam hab, das Game kam raus 2008, ich hab das schon ewig auf Steam, ich wollte das schon immer mal spielen und ich hab es nie über den ersten 2-3 Levels raus geschafft, obwohl es nicht wirklich schwierig ist.
Aber ich dachte mir, das ist ein wunderbares Game für Livestream, weil ich kann Chat lesen und wir können schwätzen.
Obwohl es hat kein Zeitlimit oder sowas.
Das ist ein super entspanntes Puzzle Game.
Ich hau nicht, dass ich es zu laut hab, ne das passt so ne.
Find den Button für YouTube PM nicht.
Ich weiß mittlerweile gar nicht mehr wie das funktioniert.
Ok, das erste sind ein paar Tutorial Levels, das ist das easy Mode.
Jetzt kriegt natürlich jeder hin.
Und ich hab es wie gesagt, ich hab nur die ersten paar Levels je gespielt, ich wollte das schon immer mal spielen.
Das gilt ja so als eines der coolsten Puzzle Games überhaupt.
Max, was hältst du eigentlich von den ganzen IT-Consulting Firmen?
In welchem Bereich oder meistens so generell, dass sich jeder irgendwie Junior-Consultant auf die Fahne schreibt?
Naja, die meisten Consultants kannst du erstmal in die Tonne kloppen.
Was viele dort können ist, die können sich gut verkaufen.
Aber Leute, die wirklich Ahnung haben, sind da recht rar gesehen.
Steht noch auf dem Schild drauf.
Ok, ich muss zur Pipe rüber, zum Rohr.
Das hätte ich mir aber auch so überlegt.
Ok, die ersten Levels sind ja immer einfach bei sowas.
Das wird doch mal bestimmt ziemlich schnell ziemlich schwer.
Ah, da Sebaro ist auch da.
Moin.
Sebaro hat gefragt, wie mein Tag war. Ich muss sagen, relativ entspannend.
Ich war ja heute nicht arbeiten.
Es ist ja Montag. Gehe ich in die Arbeit.
Deswegen war es heute entspannend. Ich war im Bauhaus.
Und habe noch mal für das Hoftor Wellen, wie heißt das?
So Wellen aus durchsichtigem Plastik gekauft.
Kann ich dann nämlich hinter das Hoftor machen.
Und dann kann die Katze, die ich mir hole, nicht durchs Hoftor klettern.
Meine alte Katze konnte auch so nicht durchs Hoftor klettern, weil die war einfach zu alt und ungelenkig dafür.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mir eine neue Katze hole oder zwei neue Katzen,
dann habe ich Angst, dass die quasi das Hoftor hochgehen und dann durchs Hoftor klettern,
weil das Hoftor hat halt relativ große Löcher drin.
Dann mache ich jetzt die Platten dahinter. Das ist halt glatt.
Da kann keine Katze hochklettern.
Und dann sind die halt da.
Was gerade die Management Consulting Firmen sind bei Arbeitnehmern ja nicht gern gesehen.
Gehen in eine Firma, reinschmeißen die Hälfte raus, das ganze Konzept durcheinander oder verschwinden.
Es kommt drauf an, in welchem Bereich die sind.
Wenn man sich für irgendwas, wo die Firma sagt, wollen wir uns nicht selbst darum kümmern oder irgendwas,
wo wir keine Ahnung von haben und wir holen uns irgendeinen, der sich das auskennt, jemand holt, das ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes dabei.
Das Problem ist eher, dass die meisten Consulting-Leute halt einfach schwätzer sind.
Wir hatten mal auf der Arbeit, hatten wir mal Consulting-Typen da aus den USA,
von irgendeiner Firma, die sich mit so Cloud-Gedöns auskennt, ich will jetzt den Namen nicht sagen.
Und die haben ab dem zweiten Tag, also sie waren den ersten Tag da, haben was gemacht.
Und den zweiten Tag haben sie festgestellt, oh, wir sind ja quasi so mitten in Frankfurt,
da können wir jetzt mal alle möglichen German-Spezialitäten ausprobieren.
Und haben sich dann ab Mittags, dem zweiten Tag nur noch German-Bier reingehauen und waren eigentlich zunächst mal zu gebrauchen.
Das hat sich natürlich nicht gelohnt, ne?
Tofu? Morgen Max, wie geht's? Oh, mir geht's gut.
Wie gesagt, ich muss heute nicht arbeiten gehen.
Naja, ich muss wahrscheinlich hier mich runterhängen lassen, ne?
Aufwachen!
Gutes Video von Anderviren-Softer, THX.
Oh, da müssen wir uns ein bisschen aufpassen.
Konnte man die Bälle nicht irgendwie wieder abmachen?
Ne, das ging, das ging mit anderen.
Ich glaube, meine Baukunste erreichen hier schnell ihr Limit in dem Game.
Hey Max, was war dein größter Scam deines Lebens, wo du gescampt wurdest?
Wo du richtig scamaßt wurdest. Oh, da muss ich mir mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Das größte, wo ich beschissen wurde.
Ich weiß, mir fällt's nicht ein.
Mir fällt das jetzt nicht ein.
Also, wo ich mich richtig verarscht, wo ich mir richtig verarscht vorkam,
das ist aber bestimmt nicht der größte Scamaß meines Lebens,
wo ich mir richtig verarscht vorkam, war bei meinem neuen Unity-Media-Anschluss,
als ich DualStack Live bekommen habe.
Das war die größte Verarschung, was providermäßig besser so passiert ist.
Damals war es ja so, damals konntest du, wenn du ein Handy hattest bei der Telekom,
also bei, weiß ich nicht, ob die mobile hießen damals,
also mein Handy hatte da in diesem Telekom-Netz, die hatten damals mobil keine IPv6-Adressen.
Und ich hatte keine Möglichkeit, mich vom Handy mehr daheim einzuloggen.
Was ich regelmäßig benutzt hab, ich hab VPN angemacht auf dem Handy,
hab dann Mails daheim gelesen, hab mir irgendwelche Sachen gesunken, alles.
Und das ging dann auf einmal nicht mehr, weil die Unity-Media der Meinung war,
wir machen DualStack Live.
Aber was war so der größte Scamaß, ich weiß es nicht.
Größte Scamaß.
Wow, was ist das?
What the fuck?
Ich wusste gar nicht, was das Spiel das Story hat.
Hat sich mal ein Freund versucht zu Scamasen?
Ich hab keine Freunde.
Naja, also ich hab nicht viele Freunde.
Keine Ahnung, ich überleg grad, was hab ich, ich glaube, ihr kennt sogar alle meine Freunde.
Oder? Lass mal überlegen.
Ich hab mit dem Fabian hab ich natürlich schon Videos gemacht.
Der Karsten, also sprich der MasterKröber, der war auch ab und zu mal in Videos.
Der Felix, mit dem ich meine Ausbildung gemacht hab, war auch schon mal in einem Video dabei.
Ansonsten, wie gesagt, ich hab relativ wenig Freunde.
In der Schule hatte ich ein bisschen mehr, nicht wirklich viel mehr Freunde.
Aber so Scamaß?
Ja, der Kabum, aber der hat mich auch nicht Scamaß.
Wobei, in der Schule, das war nicht so wirklich Scamaß.
Ich hatte zwei Kommos in der Schule, den hab ich mir super verstanden.
Der eine ging ursprünglich auf eine andere Schule als ich.
Und irgendwann ist der gewechselt auf meine Schule und hat sich zum übelsten Spaß entwickelt.
Mit dem wollte ich da nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Aber der hatte dann halt die ganzen Deppen bei mir auf der Schule, die hatten wohl irgendwie schlechten Einfluss auf ihn.
Da hat sich zum übelsten Spaß entwickelt.
Und der andere, vor allem das geile war, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch,
als ich noch in der Schule war, bzw. noch ein bisschen jünger war,
oder vielleicht seid ihr noch in der Schule, man hat irgendwelche Freunde.
Und die bringt man auch ab und zu mit heim.
Und mein Opa, der hat dann immer gesagt, wenn er da meine beiden Kumpels gesehen hat,
die werden es aber voll noch zu was bringen, weil die gute Noten geschrieben haben und so was in der Richtung.
Man wollte mir damit quasi sagen, so nach dem Motto, die bringen es ja zu viel mehr als ich,
weil die viel bessere Noten schreiben und so was.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Die haben es alle beide komplett verschissen, was das angeht.
Aber wie gesagt, der eine, mit dem ich mich da eigentlich am besten verstanden habe,
als er noch auf die andere Schule gegangen ist, der, okay, oh Gott, wie funktioniert das hier jetzt?
Der hat sich zum übelsten Spaß entwickelt, als er dann zu mir auf die Schule gegangen ist.
Aber bei mir gab es auch noch viel Spaß.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass es so gedacht ist, wie ich das hier mache, oder?
Moment.
Ich glaube, ich sollte hier noch einen hinbauen.
Ah, so ist es besser.
So, und der andere hat dann wiederum die Schule gewechselt und ist irgendwo anders hingezogen.
Und irgendwann kam er wieder und war auch der übelste Spaß.
Also insofern habe ich eigentlich auch keine Freunde bei unserer Schule.
Oh, knapp. Oh, das ist knapp. Das ist richtig knapp.
Wenn das jetzt da reingeht, dann bricht es auseinander.
Und also von meinen Freunden habe ich so, wie ich jetzt, also wenn ich jetzt, mir fällt jetzt nichts ein,
das wurde ich doch nicht so richtig verarscht.
Ich überlege gerade, ich meine, jetzt wurde ja schon jeder ein bisschen, wurde ja schon jeder gescampt.
Ich muss, ich mache mir gerade echt Gedanken, was war denn das, wo ich bisher am meisten mal gescampt wurde von irgendwas?
Zwei englische Mädels außen vor, die einem komische Dinge erzählt haben, was da nicht so war,
aber das ist ja nicht, das ist ja nicht Scam.
Was? Wo wurde ich mal gescampt so richtig?
Ich muss mir da mal Gedanken zumachen, fällt mir gerade nichts ein.
Wahrscheinlich wisst ihr das besser, weil ich das mal in einem Video erzählt habe und jetzt gar nicht dran denke.
Hey, hast du, hast auf Twitch eine Pen mit dem Google Drive Link erhalten?
Auf Twitch? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf Twitch meint.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf Twitch Messages sich anguckt, fällt mir gerade auf.
Wie kriege ich mir auf Twitch Messages?
Warte mal, Dashboard?
Ich weiß nicht, wo man Messages sich anguckt auf Twitch.
Wo geht denn das?
Video Manager? Nach Nachrichten, da ist es ja.
Angeblich habe ich keine Messages erhalten, Eingang, nichts.
Sonstiges? Sonstiges?
Twitch, please, was ist denn das für eine Logik?
Bei Twitch hat man unter Messages Eingang, Ausgang, sonstiges
und jetzt ratet mal, Chat, ratet mal in welchem Ort eine neue Message landet.
Eingang, Ausgang oder sonstiges?
Der Bot schreibt ein sinnloses Zeug, das ist noch von gestern.
Aber das Ganze ist mal aufzuklären, die Message von ihm ist in sonstiges gelandet.
Also nicht Eingang oder so, wie man das erwarten würde.
Ich habe unter sonstiges sogar mittlerweile einige PNs, die habe ich alle überhaupt mit gesehen.
WTF?
Ist auch geil, wer guckt denn bitte schön in sonstiges?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn wieder?
Okay, aber ich habe es gekriegt, die PN, alles gut.
Sonstiges normal, ja.
Ich muss mal meinem Bot beibringen, dass er nicht so komische Dinger schreibt, Moment.
Okay, Nightbot.
Wo ist der Nightbot? Hier ist der Nightbot.
Nightbot Timers, da ändern wir jetzt mal den Text.
Add Wupplos, wenn ich etwas übersehe, dann.
So, ich habe den Bottext mal geupdatet.
BDO-Frage, kann man, was kann mir ein Crystal für Arm, Moor, Claymant und kann zwischen Gathering, Fishing, Training und Processing auswählen?
Was für ein Anfang, kein Schimmer.
Ich sage doch, ich bin der best ausgerüstete BDO-Noob, ich habe von dem Gewapp keine Ahnung.
Was denkst du über die Sicherheit von Online-Banking?
Gerade mit Mobile-Tan und Banking-App auf einem Handy sehe ich das doch etwas kritischer.
Ich auch.
Da kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Man darf nicht vergessen, die ganzen Scamas-Leute sind halt immer sehr kreativ.
Moment, was muss ich hier überhaupt machen?
Ah, das sind die Dinger, die man wieder wegmachen kann.
New Go Balls.
Ah, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt gecheckt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich muss hier nach oben bauen.
Ups, so war das jetzt nicht gedacht, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Ich muss das hier nach oben bauen, dann kann ich hier unten abmachen.
So.
Moment, ich glaube, ich mache das aber falsch.
Kann ich das Ding nicht irgendwie an die Wand sticken lassen?
Ball, Ball, geh weg!
Das bleibt nicht an der Wand hängen, ne?
Ich lebe nicht so wirklich an der Wand, das wird doch niemals was, wenn das da abgeht.
Ich glaube, meine Baukünste fehlen gerade.
Das klebt da gar nicht dran an der Wand.
Warum klebt das nicht an der Wand?
Ach so, doch, funktioniert doch.
Easy.
Oh, ich sehe schon, das Spiel wird gefummelt.
Aber ich wollte es ja so.
Ich gucke gleich den Chat, falls ich was übersehen habe.
Oh, ich habe Angst, dass das gleich abbricht.
Was, nur zwei Stück? Das geht aber besser.
Ich kann das hier noch abmachen, das hier noch abmachen.
Das da, das da, das da, das da.
Okay, aber wir haben es gepackt, neun von zwei, easy.
Ja, Sebaro, frag mal den Frisör.
Heute kommt der Mercy-Nerf? Oh, nice.
Nice, ich freue mich ja, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich bin ja normalerweise nicht so extrem schadenfroh.
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht so sehr am Leid andere erfreuen.
Aber den Mercy-Mains in Overwatch, den gönne ich.
What? Den Mercy-Mains gönne ich.
Was muss man hier machen?
In das Menü soll ich gucken, okay.
Menü.
35 or more balls, easy.
Ach, hier unten, ne, das Menü.
Okay, wir müssen da oben hin.
Okay, das wird jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter.
So wird Bubble die hergestellt.
Was wird denn an Mercy generft?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das noch der aktuelle Stand ist.
Letzte Mal, was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass du nicht mehr instant retzen kannst.
Selbst in der Ultimate.
Dass, ich glaube, deine ult kürzer ist.
Und ich glaube, die Zeit, wie du fliegen kannst, wird auch irgendwie verringert oder so.
Bin ich jetzt aber nicht mal ganz sicher.
What the fuck?
Oh, ich sehe schon, das wird was.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist nicht gedacht, dass es da so stehen bleibt, oder?
Krasse Baukünste.
Ich setze da jetzt einfach mal irgendwas aneinander.
Easy clap, easy.
Nein.
Das ist ja hardcore.
Wahrscheinlich kann ich das einfach irgendwie vollbauen hier.
Ich meine, ich brauche ja bloß acht.
Ich brauche ja nur acht Goos.
Das ist ja nichts.
Zack, zack, zack, zack.
Easy geschafft.
Woher kommt der Hate gegen Mercy mains?
Als ich noch gespielt habe, waren die Hanzo mains.
Ich glaube, ich habe das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Außerdem heißt es ja nicht Hanzo, sondern wenn man cool ist, ist es Hanzo.
Ich glaube, der hauptsächliche Mercy-Held liegt daran, im Charakter selbst.
Mercy ist der Held, der mit Abstand für den wenigsten Einsatz das Höchste bringt.
Und es ist schon in gewisser Weise frustrierend, wenn man sich überlegt,
man kann sowas wie Tracer Genji gut spielen, was saumäßig schwierig ist.
Und du siehst irgendjemanden, der Mercy linke Maustaste gedrückt halten kann,
ab und zu mal Q und zwei Leute instant retten und hat damit im Endeffekt fast mehr Einfluss auf das Spiel,
als du, das sich übrigens die Seele aus dem Leib spielt.
Das ist glaube ich der hauptsächliche Hate gegen Mercy.
Dazu kommt halt auch, dass man sieht, wenn man sich die Match-Historie von den Leuten anguckt,
dass du welche hast, die waren halt, keine Ahnung, die haben hier ihre Mercy-One-Tricks gespielt,
sind dann halt quasi gewesen, irgendwie Gold, Platin, Gold, Gold, Platin, Platin, vielleicht mal Diamond oder so.
Und jetzt die letzten zwei Seasons halt GM. Das ist halt lächerlich.
Für nichts. Können im Endeffekt. Ich meine, man darf sich nicht überlegen, es heißt Grandmaster.
Und du kannst mit links klicken Grandmaster werden. Das ist halt auch nicht so.
Vom Design her auch alles nicht so tolle.
Woher kann er...
Was sagst du denn zu Slayers angekündigtem Ende?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was du meinst. Was? Hä? Was ist zu Ende?
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Oh, das wird eine Balanciere-Geschichte jetzt hier.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich hier erstmal hier runter hangeln, die Balls aufsammeln
und dann wieder nach oben.
Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall nach oben hängen und dann wieder nach oben.
Und dann wieder nach oben.
Und dann wieder nach oben. Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall mit den grünen Balls machen.
Weil die lassen sich ja wieder abkletten.
Ich hab mir absichtlich ein sehr entspanntes Gameport ausgesucht.
Aber ich glaube, das wird echt kompliziert später.
Oh ne, komm her jetzt.
Komm her. So.
Zack, dann bauen wir mal wieder hoch.
Dann bauen wir auf der anderen Seite runter. Kann man eigentlich speichern?
Das geht natürlich nicht. Wäre ja auch bescheuert, wenn das funktioniert.
Was? Ich muss eigentlich gar nicht Pause machen, ich spiele da überhaupt kein Zeitlimit.
Wat?
Tf.
Was ist das?
In Hotstars gleiche. Sehr viele, die Goldblatt waren, wurden auf einmal Masters.
Es gab vier Resets von der Season bis heute, klappt es nicht.
Also was ist so alles in allem gelesen?
Äh.
Ah.
Diese Dinger, diese Dinger machen immer, immer einen Schritt zurück, kann das sein?
Lull.
Jetzt hab ich mich selbst resettet. Perfekt Max, ganz, ganz clever gemacht.
Ich muss, ich muss die weißen Teile machen.
Ok, aber jetzt, jetzt weiß ich's.
Die resetten mich. Auch gut.
Hallo. Ich will das Ding da anklicken.
Und nicht runterfallen.
Blitz.
Ah, man kann hier nicht durchtracken. Auch gut.
So und jetzt müssen wir hier runterbauen und die anderen holen.
Hey Max, welche Programmiersprache empfiehlst du zum Anfangen?
Ähm, das hatten wir gestern schon mal kurz. Auf welcher Plattform willst du programmieren oder willst du einfach nur ein bisschen warm werden?
Also hast du was Konkretes im Kopf, was du machen willst? Oder auf welcher Plattform programmierst du?
Also quasi Mac, Windows oder?
Wo bist du unterwegs?
Ah.
Ups, das war jetzt eine blöde Idee.
Ähm.
Ohne Ankündigung 74. Gestern, gestern war krass ne?
Komplett ohne Ankündigung irgendwie 100, zwischendurch 140.
Und ich hab, ich hab ein paar Windows Forms Sachen zusammen geklickt.
Ok, es war Wochenende.
Windows.
Also wenn du Windows entwickelst, kann ich dir empfehlen, lad dir Visual Studio runter.
Ich zeig das mal, wir können das ja heute alles mal ein bisschen entspannt machen.
Ähm.
Ich mach mal kurz nen Clone auf, ich zeig dir mal was du dir da besorgen kannst.
Lad dir einfach das hier runter, Moment.
Ähm.
Capture.
Window Capture.
Was da?
Lad dir einfach die Visual Studio Community Edition runter, das da ist komplett kostenlos.
Auch wenn das Internet hier gerade ein bisschen lahm ist irgendwie, wobei ich glaub eher Microsoft ist lahm.
Oh!
Try Microsoft Edge.
Fast Secure Browser.
Also lad dir am besten Visual Studio Community 2017 runter, kost nix.
Und ähm, dann schnappst du dir das.
Galileo Open Book C Sharp.
Das da.
Und fängst an.
Das ist das beste was ich dir zum Einstieg unter Windows empfehlen kann.
Nicht retry.
Zoom.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, ich ahne Schlemmes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das wird nix.
Ach du Scheiß.
Lol.
Komm, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Goo, Goo Balls.
Zack, zack.
Bevor das wieder umkippt.
Kippt ja gar nicht um.
Dann können wir noch n bisschen besseren Score hier rausholen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nicht dass es jetzt reißt.
Okay, das kann ich in dem Art machen jetzt.
Continue.
Nice Wax Lava, du übergottene Welt.
Streams sind die besten, ja.
Find ich auch.
Macht mir auch am meisten Bock.
Übrigens heute, ne.
Ich muss mich ja mal wieder, ich muss mich ja mal wieder über YouTube auslassen.
Ich habe ja auch ein Video hochgeladen.
Über, über Virenscanner.
Und es gibt Videos, da, da nervt es mich einfach.
Das sind halt Videos, wo vielleicht manchmal was fällt, was dem einen oder anderen nicht
so gefällt, ja.
Zum Beispiel gibt es bestimmt Leute, die haben sich einen Virenscanner gekauft und die
finden es doof, dass ich nicht sage, ihr Virenscanner ist der beste.
Und ich würde ihnen empfehlen, einfach Windows Defender oder gar nichts zu verwenden.
So, im Endeffekt sage ich das ja in dem Video.
Und das sind dann solche Videos, wo ich einfach mal instant 10, 15 De-Abos kriege.
Das nervt mich.
Das, ihr könnt euch, ich meine klar, kann es jetzt im Endeffekt sagen, was juckt es
mich.
Ich meine, den meisten Leuten gefällt es doch und alles.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber das nervt mich irgendwie immer.
Und das trotz krassem Abosell auch im Video heute wieder.
Mir hat das Bad Company 1 Gameplay gefallen.
Ja, das war auch mal wieder was.
Das muss ja mal wieder sein.
Und es hat letztens einer in den Comments gefragt, so nach dem Motto, ist dir das wichtiger,
dass neue Leute abonnieren, anstatt dass es den bestehenden gefällt und sonst was.
Man kann sich auch echt an allem stören, was ich sage.
Ich meine, das eine hat ja mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Ich muss ja im Video eine kurz und knackige Sache sagen können, die passt und kann da
nicht erst mal 5 Minuten philosophieren, was mir am besten gefällt oder so.
Deswegen sage ich da mittlerweile mal einen Standard-Abo-Spruch und gut essen.
Lasst das mit dem Abosellot lieber aus.
Das bringt unglaublich viel.
Man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen.
Deswegen, ich habe ja auch früher immer gesagt, so ein Blödsinn, ja.
Aber es ist einfach so, dass viele Leute die Videos gucken und sogar regelmäßig gucken.
Ich sehe das ja über die Startseiten so.
Das heißt, die Leute gucken die Videos über die Startseite und kriegen sie auch empfohlen
über die Startseite oder über Videos, was sie nicht empfohlen bekommen würden, wenn
sie nicht mich öfters gucken würden oder nicht Leute, die ähnliche Videos machen,
zu meinen öfters gucken würden.
Und ich sehe einfach, dass total wenige Abos daraus resultieren.
Und seit ich jetzt angefangen habe, einmal im Video darauf hinzuweisen, ist das viel
mehr, ist wirklich extrem viel mehr.
Und die ganzen Social-Plate-Statistiken, die man quasi von außen sieht, sind ja nur
die halbe Wahrheit.
Wenn was Social-Plate ansteht, keine Ahnung.
Ich mache irgendwie, ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Social-Plate sagt aktuell, ich mache am Tag Daily Durchschnitt 44 Abos.
Steht jetzt da.
Na, das ist im Vergleich zu letztes Jahr immer noch immens.
Die letzten zwei Jahre habe ich Minus-Abos gemacht, weil ich kaum was hochgeladen habe.
Mittlerweile bin ich schon wieder bei ungefähr 44 am Tag.
Und, äh, wo wollte ich jetzt eigentlich drauf raus?
Lull.
Ah ja, genau.
Dass es überhaupt nichts großartig aussagt.
In Wirklichkeit sind das viel, viel, viel, viel mehr als 44 Abos am Tag.
Aber, dazu kommen natürlich, wenn man schon länger dabei ist, dann hast du halt immer
Konten, die inaktiv...
Was muss ich eigentlich machen?
Ah.
Immer Konten, die inaktiv werden, die gelöscht werden und alles mögliche in der Richtung.
Bloß halt auch Leute, die de-abonen.
Also sprich, das sind ja nur die Abos, die übrig bleiben.
Was muss ich eigentlich machen jetzt?
Fly.
Ach, ich glaube, ich muss hier, ich muss hier einen...
Ich muss an die Balls einen...
Luftballon dranhängen, ne?
Also ich finde, die Ideen für die Rätsel hier sind wirklich clever.
Auch wenn es noch die Tutorial-Welten sind.
Max, wie stehst du eigentlich zu SpaceX?
Interessierst du nicht dafür überhaupt?
Also ich hab mich relativ wenig...
Beschäftige ich mich mit, äh, was so, was so die privaten Raumfahrer...
Da und da.
Die gibt es ja nicht nur SpaceX.
Es gibt ja auch noch...
Ich hab vergessen, wie das andere heißt.
Was die so machen.
Ich kriege immer mit, ah, mal eine Rakete wird abgestürzt, mal irgendein Satellit kaputt,
mal hat alles geklappt, das Ding ist wieder gelandet.
Für, ähm, so Universum, Theorie und Weltraum und sowas interessiere ich mich extrem.
Ich gucke sau viele, sau viele, ähm, ich hab viele, viele YouTube-Channels abonniert
und gucke da sau viele Videos in der Richtung.
Was jetzt allerdings SpaceX und sowas macht an sich, äh, juckt mich nicht, muss ich sagen.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich glaube nicht, dass, ähm,
wann, wann, wann will Elon Musk auf dem Mars fliegen, 2020 oder wann war das?
Das kann ich euch am besten nicht vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass, ähm, sie, oder was, 2000, wann, wann wollte der, ne, ähm,
wann will der losfliegen, 2030 oder wann war das?
2022, irgendwie so.
Ähm, so und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie da irgendwas bauen und auch irgendwie Leute reinsetzen.
Aber wenn das wirklich starten soll, voll ich nicht ausgehe, vor allem nicht, äh, termingerecht,
dann hab ich die doofere Vermutung, dass wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die Leute lebend
auf dem Mars ankommen werden.
Ähm, geschweige denn die ganze Sache, irgendeiner überlebt von denen, die da mitmachen.
Magst du Ananas auf Pizza?
Ja, auch wenn das laut Gordon Ramsay voll verwerflich ist, mag ich das.
Hältst du Zeitreisen für möglich realistisch?
Äh, in die Zukunft? Ja, in die Vergangenheit nicht.
Was muss ich jetzt hier machen?
Soll ich jetzt rüberfliegen?
Äh, ah, ich glaub ich hab's gecheckt, was ich machen muss.
Ich muss, oh, oh, das wird, das wird ein Balanceakt hier.
Okay, funktioniert.
Okay, wir bauen das jetzt mal möglichst, ah, du Scheiße.
Wir bauen das jetzt hier mal möglichst gerade.
Wow!
Ah, da oben sind auch Stacheln.
Ähm, oh, da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich lese gleich den Rest im Chat.
Die Physik der Gobel ist ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist knapp, das ist knapp, das ist, oh, das ist knapp.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, oh, fuck.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Hä, das ist schwieriger als ich mir das vor, nein, nein, nein, okay, passt das?
Das ist schwieriger als ich mir das vorgestellt hab gerade.
Was hab ich da eigentlich für ein komisches Ding gebaut?
Das ist doch komplett sinnlos.
Nein, nein, ich wollt den Ball doch gar nicht dahin machen.
Fuck.
Das ist ja ein Scheiß zusammen, äh, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist, das ist echt knapp was ich hier baue.
Oh, oh, mit dem letzten Gobel.
Was ist das für eine Konstruktion, was für eine Konstruktion.
Aber es hat geklappt.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz chat hochscrollen.
Hallo Mr. Unlocker.
Ähm, der Anwalt fragt, was meine Lieblingsidee ist.
Also ich muss sagen, unter Windows, auch wenn Microsoft Produkte immer viel Hate abbekommen, aber gegen Visual Studio kann man eigentlich nichts schlechtes sagen.
Es ist alles mal, also ich kann nicht sagen, was meine, was meine gehassteste beziehungsweise meine unbeliebteste Idee ist und das ist eindeutig Eclipse.
So was aufgeplasenes, hässliches hab ich ja selten benutzen müssen.
Ähm, aber unter Windows muss ich sagen, Visual Studio ist super für alles was halt, ja, halt Windows und, und.NET mäßig ist.
Und für C++ finde ich, was auch ziemlich gut ist, ist der Cute, die, ne, äh, Creator heißt der, Creator.
Der Cute Creator, der ist auch super.
Also ich würde sagen, Visual Studio und, äh, Cute Creator.
Wenn du TV schaust, was schaust du eher an Dokus oder Serienfilme?
Talkshows danach, ich guck eigentlich gar kein Fernsehen.
Also wenn, wenn ich mal irgendwas gucke, dann, dann vielleicht irgendwelche Doku-Geschichten oder so, ich guck eigentlich nix.
Ich guck eigentlich, ich, das mittlerweile muss ich sagen, ich, ich bin ja, wie gesagt, ich bin 84 geboren, ja.
Ähm, das ist eigentlich so die, die letzte Generation, die so noch mit Fernseher aufgewachsen ist, zu der ich gehöre.
Also noch ohne YouTube und Internet und Zeug.
Ich bin ja quasi so die letzte Generation, die das betrifft.
Ähm, aber ich glaube ich, im Umkehrfall war ich einer der ersten, der quasi, oder gehör ich auch auch zur ersten Generation,
wo viele komplett auf Fernsehen verzichten.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das kann sein, ja.
Fernsehen in 2K18, äh, in 2K18, Leute, ja.
A real Tower of Goo.
Ich hab die Story von dem Spiel immer noch nicht verstanden, falls da jetzt wirklich einer hat.
Wie hoch muss ich denn?
Äh, okay, das ist echt hoch.
Da, da müssen wir, da müssen wir ein bisschen breiter anfangen.
Achtung, Max-Architekten-Skills sind jetzt gefragt.
Maximum-Architekten-Skills.
So, ich hoffe mal, das ist breit genug.
Wir machen jetzt so eine Art Eiffelturm hier.
Ich glaube, das ist das letzte, das letzte Level.
Zu, vom, vom Tutorial.
Oh, das ist jetzt schon shab.
Das ist jetzt schon shab.
Okay, wir gleichen das mal ein bisschen aus.
Wie viel, 25, na gut, ich hab ja auch ganz schön viele.
Das ist nicht gerade, oder, was ich hier baue?
Oh, es, oh, es kommt auch noch Wind dabei.
Ach du.
Okay, dann müssen wir das hier ein bisschen, ein bisschen schwerer bauen als auf der anderen
Seite.
Aber fuck, guck mal, wie hoch wir noch müssen.
Oh nee, das wird nix.
Ach du Scheiße, nee, das wird nix.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh fuck.
Oh, ey, Moment, es lebt, es lebt.
Oder auch nicht.
Scheiße.
Ich hab, oh Mann, das wird nix, ach du Scheiße.
Ich baue jetzt, ich baue jetzt einfach so schnell.
Der hat ja auch geschrieben, ich soll schnell, oh fuck ey.
Warte mal, jetzt kann ich doch rückgängig machen, oder?
Ich glaube, ich muss noch mal anfangen.
Das wird so nix.
Scheiße.
Okay, wir fangen noch mal an.
Das muss anders, das müssen wir anders machen.
Das, das funktioniert so nicht.
Okay, wir müssen das breiter bauen.
So, ha?
Okay, okay, jetzt ist es echt breit.
Was, Game is Black Desert?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich weiß nicht, was der, hör nicht auf den Nightbot, was der da erzählt.
Der Nightbot hat keine Ahnung.
Okay, was gibt es hier auf dem Schild?
Go as fast as you can.
Okay, das heißt, das heißt, as fast as I can, das ist die Taktik hier, oder was?
Ja, das ist die Taktik hier, oder was?
Go, go, jetzt, jawoll, zackig, zackig, zackig, zackig, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein.
Easy Clap, Easy Clap, überhaupt kein Ding, überhaupt kein Ding.
Ja, das stimmt nicht so ganz, was der geschrieben hat mit Game Black Desert, das ist falsch.
Was ist das Ziel von dem Spiel, zur Röhre zu kommen?
Wann der Subbutton kommt, ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab Twitch immer noch nicht angefragt,
eingeschrieben.
Benutzst du dein ab und zu deines Mitch?
Nee, das letzte, was ich drauf gespielt hab, ist Mario, all I see.
Gibt ja nichts, es gibt ja nichts auf der Switch.
Da wird mir jetzt zwar der Nintendo Fan widersprechen, aber was gibt es denn auf der Switch?
Es gibt Zelda, es gibt Mario, es gibt vielleicht noch Splatoon, wenn man da drauf steht.
Es gibt dieses Mario Rabbids Spiel, wenn man da drauf steht.
Es gibt, was gibt es denn sonst auf der Switch?
Moment, das gucken wir uns jetzt mal zusammen an.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz die Switch Games an.
Und dann sag ich euch, was mir davon gefällt und was nicht.
Gibt es auch keine Liste für Switch Spiele, die 2018 rausgekommen sind?
Das überrascht mich jetzt aber.
Und vor allem 2017, nicht 2018.
Wo gibt es denn Switch Spiele?
Release Liste aktueller, ja, gucken wir mal.
Guck mal, Best Switch Games 2017.
Guck mal, jetzt kann ich mich sogar verschrieben.
Jetzt kann ich sogar sagen, Best Swatch Games 2017 funktioniert.
Also, gutes Game, gutes Game.
Bestimmt ganz okay, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Ich war noch nie groß das Splatoon Fan.
Übrigens, weil jetzt sagt der Max Frist wieder, ich habe hier Trauben.
Also, nicht so, nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche ungesunden Sachen puttern würde oder so.
So, Mario Kart 8 Deluxe ist nicht übel.
Mario Kart 8 generell war nicht übel.
Was ich sagen muss, ich finde, ich fand Mario Kart war schon immer dadurch gekennzeichnet, dass es absolut random ist.
Aber ich habe persönlich den Eindruck, dass Mario Kart 8 fast noch das random mixte Mario Kart überhaupt ist.
Was mich ein bisschen genervt hat.
Ich fand das Mario Kart auf der Wii richtig geil.
Ich fand das auf dem DS richtig geil.
Und ich finde Mario Kart 8 auch ganz gut.
Aber das ist bei mir jetzt in meiner Mario Kart Liste nicht so weit oben.
Wobei es mittlerweile viel mehr Strecken und alles gibt als früher.
Was ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe, warum es Link in einem Mario Kart Spiel gibt.
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil Nintendo mittlerweile auch verstanden hat, es geht darum, was die Leute für Charaktere spielen wollen.
Scheißegal, ob sie zum Universum gehören oder nicht.
Okay.
Also, fangen wir mal an. Gutes Game.
Also, auf jeden Fall die ersten beiden absolut top Games.
Gibt es nichts dazu zu sagen, eines der besten Spiele, die überhaupt rausgekommen sind.
So, die ersten beiden.
Splatoon, wem es gefällt.
Mario Kart 8 auch nicht übel.
Mario und Rabbids eigentlich auch ganz nett.
ARMS.
Da muss ich sagen, bin ich ein bisschen enttäuscht von Nintendo, was ARMS angeht.
Sie haben das im Vorfeld angekündigt als ARMS eSport League oder so.
Haben sie mal irgendwo erzählt, ja.
Nintendo ARMS is joining the world of eSports. Blablabla.
Also so nach dem Motto, boah, wir haben ganz tolle Ambitionen mit dem Game.
Und jetzt kam letztens die Message, ARMS ist eingestellt.
Jawoll.
So macht man ein tolles Competitive Multiplayer Spiel, indem man es ein paar Monate nach Release einstellt.
Das easy clap, das ist ganz toll, Nintendo.
Xenoplade Chronicles 2 soll ziemlich gut sein.
Und das war's.
Das heißt, wir haben im Endeffekt zwei Must-have Games, wofür es sich ohne Frage lohnt, eine Switch zu kaufen.
Wenn man halt eine Wii U hat, kann man sagen, hey, eigentlich kann ich das Zelda auch da drauf spielen.
Am Ende genommen, man hätte keine Wii U, was ja viele Leute betrifft.
Also, Must-have, ja.
Allein schon für die zwei Games kann man sich eine Switch kaufen.
Rest ist so, naja.
Und bis hier eigentlich auch noch alles ganz gut.
Also gäbe es, wenn man angenommen ist, gefällt einem alles das hier, gibt es aktuell eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben...
Nein, wie gesagt, mittlerweile eigentlich eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, wir sagen mal fünf oder sechs Games.
Wobei es für mich halt einfach nur zwei Games sind.
Und das ist einfach zu wenig.
Das ist einfach zu wenig.
Ich meine, dass sich da andere Konsolen, wie jetzt die neuen Sachen, die für Microsoft, für die Xbox rauskommen, auch noch nicht so...
nicht mit Ruhm bekleckern, das macht es jetzt ja auch nicht besser im Endeffekt.
So, was haben wir noch nach rechts?
Snipperclips.
Nett. Nett, ja.
Sonic Mania.
Soll ganz gut sein, kannst du aber, glaube ich, auch auf allen anderen Plattformen spielen und hatte, glaube ich, FPS-Probleme auf das mit.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das neue Fire Emblem ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn das was taugt, ist das bestimmt auch ein ganz gutes Game.
Golf Story, was auch immer, kein Schimmer.
Fast Ares.
Das ist dieses F-Zero, was kein F-Zero ist, das ist aber auch irgendeine Neuauflage von etwas altem, das soll auch ganz gut sein.
FIFA 18.
Guck mal, da steht sogar... da ist sogar die PS4.
Da ist sogar die PS4-Packung auf der Konsole.
Denkst, wenn man nach Switch sucht.
Beschissenste FIFA-Portierung.
FIFA um aller Zeiten für die Switch.
1-2-Switch.
Hör mal auf, da sag ich nichts zu NBA.
Juckt nicht.
Steam-Digqual ist, glaube ich, ganz gut, aber es hat alles jetzt nichts, wofür man sich unbedingt eine Switch kaufen muss.
Wolfenstein muss man sich definitiv keine Switch kaufen.
Joka L.A. muss man sich auch keine Switch verkaufen.
Man kann es überall woanders spielen.
Sonic 2017, nein.
Nein.
Das neue Bomberman zackt auch.
Das ist auch eine Neuauflage von irgendwas altem.
Glaub ich.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, das ist doch schon ein bisschen älter.
Lego-Spiele gibt es auch überall anderes, was auch immer das hier ist.
Gibt es bestimmt auch überall anders.
Snake Pass gibt es auch überall anders.
Also das war es im Endeffekt.
Es bleiben zwei Must-Have-Spiele für die, den Rest gibt es auch für andere Plattformen.
Im Prinzip gibt es zwei Must-Have-Spiele für die Switch.
Das ist das hier.
Und ein ziemlich gutes, wenn man noch so was steht, mit Xenoblades.
Und dann, und vielleicht noch Mario Kart.
Da sagen wir, das, das, das und Mario Kart.
Da hast du wirklich, wenn du mit viel Wohlwollen hast, kannst du dir, selbst wenn du hier die andere noch mitnimmst.
Es kommt jeder auf, sagen wir mal, ungefähr vier Spiele, die ihm gefallen könnten auf der Switch zur Zeit.
Und es ist halt ein bisschen wenig, ne?
Ah ja, Skyrim gibt es, hab ich vergessen.
Gibt es das mittlerweile schon?
Gibt es eigentlich, gibt es eigentlich Skyrim schon?
Wobei Skyrim für mich natürlich auch kein Grund ist, sich die Switch zu kaufen.
Außer, dass man es mitnehmen kann.
Okay, wer Skyrim schon immer mal mobil spielen wollte.
Ja, okay, okay.
Aber die beste Skyrim-Version, krass, definitiv auf dem PC.
Und man merkt Skyrim mittlerweile an, dass es in die Jahre gekommen ist.
Ich meine, wie oft wollen sie denn Skyrim noch raushauen?
Skyrim gibt es ja gefühlt quasi für, für alles.
Das kam, wann kam Skyrim raus?
Ich kann nicht mal richtig reden.
Skyrim kam 2011 oder so raus?
Skyrim Release Date.
2011, Ende 2011 kam das raus.
Ich meine, überlegt mal, das Spiel ist sieben Jahre alt.
Und da gibt es jetzt neu, das wird als grandios geil und neu angeprieselt auf sieben Jahre später.
Das kommt.
Irgendwann ist ja auch mal, ist ja mal irgendwie, ist aber auch mal gut mit Skyrim.
Okay, Bridge-Builder-Style.
Nein, so funktioniert das definitiv nicht.
Ich muss, ich muss, ich muss das, warte mal, ich mach mal anders.
Schwachsinn.
Ich muss da ein bisschen nach hinten bauen.
Es ist eigentlich ziemlich easy.
So muss man das machen.
Wir müssen da erstmal ordentlich nach hinten so Gewicht dran bauen.
Und dann können wir nach vorne weiter machen.
Irgendwie so.
Ich glaube, das passt schon, was ich da mache, so halbwegs.
Na ja, fast, krasse, krasse Building-Skills.
Vielleicht soll ich das noch ein bisschen hier zusammenbauen.
Ich sehe halt auch die Hälfte irgendwie nicht.
Ich glaube, das, was ich hier mache, ist irgendwie eine ziemlich dämliche Idee.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Ich glaube, ich fange nochmal neu an.
Warte mal, Leute, ich fange nochmal neu an.
Das klappt, das klappt so nicht.
Das ist bescheuert.
Okay, im Prinzip ist es doch ganz einfach.
Zack, zack, zack, wir bauen jetzt einfach so weit, bis es anfängt runterzufallen.
So, und wenn es anfängt runterzufallen, bauen wir hier hinten was dran.
Und dann zieht es das wieder hoch.
Ich sehe halt nichts, so wirklich.
Und jetzt zieht es das, sollte es das, naja.
Irgendwie sind meine Bridge-Bilder-Sachen jetzt auch nicht so toll.
Wie weit muss ich denn da eigentlich...
Ach, das ist ja gar nicht mal so weit.
Ach ja, stimmt.
Das neue Monster Hunter ist ja am Start.
Das wollte ich ja eigentlich mit dem Fabian mal ausprobieren.
Max, was du da baust, funktioniert nicht, oder doch?
Nein, Max, Max, das ist nichts.
Max, das funktioniert so nicht.
Das ist eine ziemlich bescheuerte Idee, was du hier baust.
Ich glaube, ich muss nochmal anfangen.
Ich bin da zu dumm für, das gibt es doch nicht.
Okay, okay, ganz, ganz, ganz ruhig.
Oder muss ich...
Warte mal, ich baue nach hier unten was.
Hier unten kommt noch was hin.
Jawoll, hier unten kommt noch, so ist das gut.
So.
Oh fuck, das wollte ich gar nicht.
Scheiße.
Kann ich nochmal rückgängig machen?
So, ja, so ist das schick.
Staticore, ja, echt krasser Staticore.
So und jetzt, jetzt weiß ich was, jetzt bauen wir hier hinten, jetzt bauen wir hier hinten
hoch und lassen es einfach zurückziehen.
So, genau, okay.
So, das klappt, das klappt.
Oder auch nicht.
Fuck man, warum bin ich denn so schlecht für dieses Game, äh?
Staticore am Berg, äh.
Das wird doch nie was.
Alter, wie soll das was werden?
Ach du Scheiße.
Schreckt.
Oh, ich hab zu wenig Balls.
Fuck.
Okay, wie viel hab ich jetzt?
Oh nee, jetzt hab ich zu wenig Balls, ich glaub's nicht.
Kann ich noch irgendwo mal rückgängig machen?
Okay.
Next MLG-Taktik hochbauen und umfallen lassen, nee.
Jetzt mach ich es mal auf, das ist gar nicht so schwer, das machen wir jetzt einfach.
So weiter zack
So easy startekurs
Guck mal, das ist doch überhaupt kein Ding, das kriegt doch... easy clap
Ha, guck mal, überhaupt kein Ding. Man sollte nicht versuchen, irgend so'n Scheiß zu bauen
Sondern einfach geradeaus drüber. Man muss ja auch nicht alles total überdenken
Hochbau steht auf dem Schild, guck mal jetzt hier, guck mal, wie viele von acht wir da kriegen
Ok, was hab ich jetzt überlesen im Chat? Zeig mal her. Ich habe ganz viel verpasst, nachdem ich jetzt hier dieses komische Dylers verbauen musste
So, es gibt viele Diskussionen über wie und Switch. Snapper Clips ist der Kaufgrund für die Switch, ja genau
Was sagst du zu Nintendo Labo? Du meinst dieses Pappzeug? Ich finde das ist eine geile Idee
Ich möchte jetzt anfangen zu programmieren. Kannst du mir Tipps für den Anfang geben? Ja, das hatten wir gerade eben schon mal
Ich würde dir empfehlen, du bist wahrscheinlich unter Windows unterwegs
Lad dir Wishlist Studio Community Edition runter und fang an
Nehm dir noch das Galileo Open Press, die Scharpbuchenfang anzulernen
An welchem Level fängt man eigentlich in BDO mit dem Grind an? Durchgängig
Man levelt nicht über Quests. Quests brauchen wir nur für Contribution Points. Man grindet quasi von 1 bis 60
Du levelst ja auch in einem Tag bis 54 oder so
Ist da Fabian noch Friseur?
Soweit ich weiß arbeitet er noch im Friseursalon und kümmert sich jetzt eher um organisatorische Dinge
Verstehe den Hype um Monster Hunter gar nicht. Ich habe es 3 Stunden gespielt und dann vor langer Weile ausgebaut
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen. Ich habe das neue Monster Hunter noch gar nicht ausgebaut. Ich wollte das mit dem Friseur spielen
Wir wollten uns einfach mal angucken, weil es ja auch Leute ansprechen soll wie mich, die mit Monster Hunter bisher nicht so viel anfangen konnten
Wer macht deiner Meinung nach die besten Mäuse Tastatur und Headsets?
Headsets, Bio Dynamics, also es gibt eigentlich nichts was über das MMX300 geht, immer noch wenn man die Kohle hat
Oder mal ein bisschen gespart hat. Wir sind im Magen gelandet anscheinend. Mäuse Tastatur und Mäuse, an sich hätte ich immer gesagt Logitech
Aber ich habe jetzt ja, wie gesagt ich hatte lange die zum testen die G502 oder G402, die Pro Toy Score oder wie das Ding hieß
Die waren mir zu schwer und ich habe seitdem von Zoe, also das ist BenQ, die EC2A, da gibt es jetzt mittlerweile auch die EC2B
Ich glaube ich habe diese Neuauflage davon und ich muss sagen das ist so eine simple Maus, die hat nichts. Das ist einfach eine Maus mit zwei Seitentasten
Eine Maus hat zwei Knöpfe links und rechts, die finde ich richtig gut. Und Tastaturen würde ich ausprobieren was mir gefällt
Also ich würde sagen Headsets, ein MMX300 von Bio Dynamics oder eben irgendein x beliebiges gutes Audio Kopfhörer und ein Modmic dabei
Dann für mich hier eine Zoe EC2A, mit der sogar Taimo spielt. Taimo spielt jetzt ja nicht mal mehr DBS, aber das ist einfach mein Lieblings Offerwärtsspieler
Und Tastature kann ich immer
Also ich muss sagen die Levels sind echt kreativ gemacht hier. Ich glaube irgendwie ich muss nach unten bauen, kann das sein, sodass es nicht mehr so hin und her wackelt jetzt erst mal
Weil solange es hin und her wackelt ist das ziemlich kacke